Sáng nay ngày 15, 18, 18, các lực lượng của sả la lai đồn biến phòng la lai.
Công an tình quan chỉ tích tục trường 2 tình kiểm tại xế mất tích trong vũ lũ lũ cốn tại cầu chàn thương Azochên.
Chức xây tại đoất phát hiện dưới lòng sối, nằm giữa khu vực dòng trẻ mạnh,
lực lượng trức năng đăng tính hành đánh dấu, khoan vùng, khảo xa điện địa trình bị chục bất.
Công tắt tình kiểm vừa lại xây được trường 2 theo nhiều hướng,
giọc theo đường sối, các vùng nước xảy và cả những đường điểm ghi có vật cả,
tường tổ con tắc tục trực lượng tất dụng từ khoảng phép ra nước dút để tiếp cận.
Chứ đó, vào trước qua anh đến tàn thành, sinh 1 in chỉ trăm bệm mới bệnh, ngụ quảng chỉ,
đều khiến xây đầu kéo bệm mới làm hát khâu không bệm bụp bà.
Lưu thông theo rử tự cửa khẩu cuối tế là lai về cuối lộ chính, khi đến gần chàn thương Azochên,
xa la lai, giọ bất cần, bội vang, anh thành đã lại xây đi qua ngầm chàn dụn nước xân khảo, chảy sếp,
khi xây điên dụn khảo chàn, giọc nước mạnh của dởi các bên, tại sẽ chào lên tụng xây, không lâu sau, nước lũ cao,
chảy sếp cũng cảm ồi bệnh trước xây.